many many countries the U the gap
between the political lead and the fox
popular is is is is very very large and
um if that bridge will not be um will
not be crossed then uh I think um um it
will be even sooner that there would
come a majority of people who fight
against it so that question I suppose is
actually a component of a larger
question which is that there many people
in the United States who say Europe is
lost the demographic uh data is so
prohibitive that there will be Muslim
majorities very soon in most of the
Western European countries and that uh
the elites are so supine or either
either either supine or
complicit what possible hope can there
be yes do you hold our hope for the
future of yes well I I I what I hope uh
what I also said when I spoke uh at a
lunch meeting for the Hudson Institute
in New York this week I hope that
America will not be the last man
standing that um if um in a few years or
few decades time they will wake up one
day and said who the hell lost Europe
who lost Europe Europe is gone we had
here an ally and it's gone it's it's
it's became it became an Islamic Europe
and we have no uh partner politically we
have no partner economically we have no
partner military it's a go gum our
friend became the enemy and and the only
country to defend our values and to
defend the heritage of of of Rome and
and Venice and Jerusalem will be America
um um help us not to let that happen and
what can we do we can Implement laws
like I said anti Sharia laws we can be
far more tougher on our immigration laws
it's really important because indeed you
are fully right that um if you look at
the demographics um we are already
losing that war I mean in my country the
birth rate is something like 1.8% as you
know you need 2.1% and most of of our um
um um Moroccan or Arab or Islamic um
people in my country have something like
2.6 or seven or eight and it's it's all
over Europe it's the same fortunately in
America this is not the case yet so we
have to think about it as the fact that
we are in fact in a war but um like in
the past it's it's not a conventional
War it's not that the the armies of the
Arabs are in front of the gates of of of
yenna uh as it was some centuries ago at
or at at parier this is not the case any
I wish it was conventional because then
people could see who the enemy was and
they were willing to fight it it's not
conventional it's done by uh
demographics it's done by immigration
and it's done by appeasement by the
elite and um we cannot win this war if
we take measures both on Shara both on
immigration
when it comes to when is are people
welcome in your country and are not I
mean we should really take an enormous
effort because um we are a war and our
leaders um are uh surrendering before
they even fult yes they are yes and uh
for many time in many cases it's because
of uh very shortsighted political or
economic calculations and of course
Sharia Finance is a very grave problem
with the uh the wholesale buying up of
so much of uh the Western properties
Western Capital Western Capital assets
so many things uh what would you say to
uh Bankers to financiers to economists
who think that it's a it's it's a simple
necessity to make various concessions
and accommodations to deal with the
Islamic world and Islamic Finance yes
well I say I I I say to them to those
Bangles as I say to other people that
are accommodating that it sounds on the
short term it might sound attractive for
your business but in the long term you
will pay the price and uh that will be
the price will be that um you will have
nothing to say anymore about your
investment about your bank it will be it
will be gone entirely it will be out of
your hands don't think you are dealing
with a Swiss bank or a bank from the
Caribbean or whatsoever you are dealing
and with a bunch of people that at the
end of the day I want to want to submit
you I want to rule you I want to enforce
on your their ideology and you will have
nothing to say and you will have help
them um um um um making your own grave
and this is something that um people
should be around and should not do yes
it's uh well of course that's the main
problem there's no awareness of these
issues exactly and uh that also is of
course that's why we're having this
interview is one small step or one small
blow in trying to uh overturn the
hegemony of the mainstream do you find
that in the Netherlands the mainstream
press coverage is uh as uninformed as
ignorant as perhaps also complicit in
this as the government is also yeah they
are they are very very complicit of
course there are some exceptions but U
95% of the Dutch press is uh is is is is
leftish is liberal is politically
correct um is um um um is not objective
in any possible way and this this is one
of our major problems indeed Robert not
only in Netherlands but all my
colleagues from all the other countries
and maybe it's the same even in the
United States that it's very hard to get
some honest press press uh um um um
covering um whether you make a speech or
whether you write an article or even if
you write a book and they will label you
as as as as as racist as as fascist even
only when you talk about if you use one
word about Islam or or diud and U um um
um in my country we paying a lot of
billions of taxpayers money to a huge
public um um uh Broadcasting Company and
it's very unfair because at least we
should have more liberal or more
conservative left and right kind of uh
of broadcasting companies and we don't
it's 95% one-sided and it's nowadays so
important so important people um hardly
unfortunate
read the Common People Le books or
whatsoever they they watch TV almost
almost all day so if you're on TV the
image that you can TV is so very
important um so I believe that's what I
proposed as an N that we should get rid
totally of the public TV maybe at one
channel when there was something going
on uh and for the rest let the market
U let the market decide what will uh be
broadcasted and I'm sure that um our
voters our electorate is more balanced
than uh the media today and everybody is
paying for that yes absolutely everybody
is uh so I understand that you've been
getting some mainstream press coverage
in the United States while you've been
here the last few days yes yes and well
when I'm this is It's always for me it's
a it's an enormous uh privilege to be in
the United States even though with all
the security surrounding it it's a it's
like coming home I have the same feeling
when I go to uh Israel many times when I
arrive at Boran aor or when I arrive at
Washington on the York airport when I
meet people like yourself but also other
people it's like it's like it's like
another world not only the Free World
but it's like there are more people uh
um um um in in support and in
understanding than at least when you
look at the at the level of the elite uh
in Europe and it's it's very strange
that's why I'm not only so proud about
what America is doing even though it
makes a lot of mistakes but it's it's
almost the last Bastion um of freedom
and my message to my message is to every
American I tell to you are uh losing
Europe you will be the last man standing
don't mess up yourself uh but make sure
that you invest in your European allies